of the four main men on the Big Bang
Theory Raj Koothrappali played by Kunal
Nayyar was perhaps the most socially
awkward Raj's difficulties with women
resulted in some painfully uncomfortable
situations one of which involved Raj
doing the absolute worst thing he's ever
done you went out with him I didn't
throughout the Big Bang Theory Raj the
self-proclaimed romantic of the group
tries to have a successful relationship
with a woman but Falls horribly short
for a number of reasons on more than one
occasion he requests that his parents
organized an arranged marriage with a
woman from a good Indian family and
every single one of them ends up failing
miserably a list of his other romantic
mishaps include dating two women at once
rifling through her girl's closets and
drawers when she leaves him alone in her
house leaving one girl for another after
the briefest of meetings with the latter
and then coming crawling back to his ex
when a girl turns him away pushing women
way out of their comfort zone referring
to women he's not attracted to his
fatties and uggos and spying on his
fiancee and that's not even to mention
him fantasizing about his friends wives
and girlfriends throughout the show even
almost hooking up a penny one night what
were you thinking
easily the worst thing Raj did however
was the ISA Bela on the season 10
episode entitled the brain bowl
incubation Raj meets the beautiful
maintenance worker when she comes into
his lab at Caltech to clean late one
night
despite the instant spark between them
if he comes clear that Raj has a problem
with ISA bellas job after hitting it off
with isa Bela in his lab Raj helps her
clean the bathrooms during their
cleaning session he decides to ask
Isabela on a date but she explains she
doesn't have time to date while working
two jobs before leaving the bathroom he
tries to convince his Avella to change
her mind and she again turns him down
the rest of the gang quickly picks up on
the fact that Raj has met someone you're
dating somebody who is it
Viraj makes a fatal and cruel mistake
when he fails to correct their
assumption that she's also an astronomer
what for a supposedly intelligent man
this is a stupid move
still Raj cooks up a plan to surprise
her and get the date he wants it's a
little pushy and desperate after she's
already turned him down twice in the
bathroom when Isabela next walks into
his lab he set up a romantic dinner
complete with flowers in a tablecloth
for them to enjoy things seem to be
going swimmingly and that Howard walks
in and casually mentions oh yeah the
astronomer Raj told us about you you can
actually see ISA bail
faceball as she instantly realizes Raj
has lied about her job and rightly
points out that she doesn't need to
waste her time with someone who's
embarrassed by what she does for a
living
she makes a quick exit from the lab
dragging her cleaning cart with her as
she goes Raj tries to go after he
Sabella and apologize saying he couldn't
believe how shallow he was being
honestly I didn't think your job would
bother me
but I guess it did and I hate myself for
that fortunately isabella has enough
respect for herself to walk away from
someone who clearly won't respect her
Raj knew at ICI Bela did before even
started pursuing her and continued to
chase her knowing full well he would
never be comfortable telling his friends
that she's a cleaning lady at the
University and not another scientist
what exactly did he think was going to
happen it's such a blatant lie that
there's no way anyone will convince us
Raj truly thought their relationship
would be able to go anywhere without the
light coming out the shame you felt over
ISA Bella's job is even more ironic when
we consider the fact that at that point
in time Raj was still living off his
father's fortune to pay for his rent
made car and credit card bills something
he seems oddly proud of I grew up with a
house full of servants and now I've been
cleaning lady who is a lovely woman
we'll have great respect for at least
ISA Bella is making a living off her own
money Raj really has no leg to stand on
with this classism here I have a car
whose doors open like oh it's never
acceptable to make someone else feel
ashamed about what they do and Raj hit
rock bottom with his treatment of ICI
Bella during this episode of The Big
Bang Theory watching him lie to his
friends about easy Bella's job makes it
easy to understand why Raj has so many
problems with women check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about the Big Bang Theory
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
you
[Music]